bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne les travaux de la
mission d'information du sénat sur la
filière viande en france et en europe
cet après midi elle les sénateurs
organise une table ronde sur la question
de l'abattage rituel
il faut dire que le scandale de la
viande de cheval avait également
éclaboussé la communauté musulmane et
que régulièrement certaines affaires
sortent dans la presse concernant et
bien de la viande faussement vendu comme
halal alors sans plus tarder direction
la salle de médicis pour suivre cette
table-ronde de bonne après midi à tous
bien merci messieurs de vous être rendu
à notre invitation
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir pour
cette audition sous forme de tables
rondes
monsieur kamel cape town recteur de la
mosquée de lyon
monsieur calimero recteur de la mosquée
d'evry
monsieur tchèque alcide responsable du
service à la halle de la mosquée de
paris et monsieur mohamed moussaoui
président du conseil français du culte
musulman
vous avez répondu à notre invitation
pour cette mission d'information sur la
filière viande qui a été demandée par le
groupe centriste
udi du sénat est mise en place en accord
avec les responsables du sénat avec pour
objectif de d'examiner la les
productions animales l'abattage et la
transformation des produits ainsi que la
commercialisation des produits
nous avons mené jusque là un certain
nombre d'auditions qui nous ont permis
d'avancer sur un certain nombre de
points
et avant de passer au questionnaire qui
vous a été adressé
et qui va servir de trame à notre
entretien je donne la parole à madame
goy chavent qui est rapporteur de la
mission et qui souhaitent poser les
bases de notre dialogue
merci madame la présidente tout d'abord
messieurs je tiens à vous remercier
infiniment d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation et à vous dire que j'attends
beaucoup de cette audition je me permets
un petit préambule avant de vous donner
la parole la france garantit à tous la
liberté de conscience et la liberté de
culte est ici nous y tenons tous et j'y
tiens tout particulièrement c'est dans
le cadre de cette garantie que la france
permet au musulman mais également aux
juifs de s'alimenter selon leur culte de
se nourrir de viande certifiée ou non
halal ou casher c'est à dire de viande
permise par la loi religieuse et donc
issus de filières d'abattage rituel et
je tiens à dire que je n'ai absolument
rien contre l'abattage rituel
il faut que ce soit très clair entre
nous sans remettre bien sûr ce droit en
cause ce droit fondamental je
m'interroge sur là pratiques d'abattage
rituel halal sans étourdissement
préalable
en effet il apparaît que de nombreux
pays notamment de nombreux pays
musulmans impose l'étourdissement
préalable des animaux de boucherie et la
france importe aussi quotidiennement de
la viande certifiée halal et pourtant
issus de chaînes d'abattage avec
étourdissement préalable d'abattage
rituel bien sûr rien dans le coran
n'interdit l'étourdissement préalable
des animaux avant leur abattage et la
jurisprudence islamique n'apporte pas de
réponse définitive sur ce sujet dès lors
pourquoi la pratique de l'abattage sans
étourdissement préalable et l répandu en
france
sinon pour répondre à une frange de
musulmans peut-être plus radicaux en
effet cela musulmans sur deux d'après ce
que j'ai pu lire serait très attaché à
l'étourdissement préalable
contrairement aux produits casher
garantie par le consistoire central
des juifs de france il n'existe pas dans
l'hexagone de label halal
c'était pourtant une des missions
confiées au conseil français du culte
musulman lors de sa création en 2003 en
vain malheureusement dans les faits
trois mosquées
vous me direz si vous confirmez ou
nantes trois mosquées paris lyon et evry
sont habilitées à délivrer des cartes de
sacrificateurs mais ce sont ensuite des
multi d'une multitude d'organismes qui
effectuent des contrôles notamment dans
les abattoirs avec des méthodes et des
définitions du halal parfois un petit
peu différente
certaines entreprises sont quant à elles
auto certifiés ou emploi elle même les
contrôleurs par ailleurs certains
organismes de certification halal
appartiennent à des noms de musulmans
nous savons tous ici à quelle entreprise
je fais allusion
si le rite halal est bel et bien à rite
religieux là dessus pas de souci la
certification halal n'est elle pas avant
tout un marché juteux qu'il conviendrait
enfin de réguler jeu pour ma part un ami
musulmans très pratiquants qui m'a dit
quand ma femme va faire les courses
elle aimerait avoir la garantie vraiment
la garantie que les produits carnés ou
non qu'elles achètent sont réellement
halal et il a peur d'une dérive alors
c'est une question autre chose pour des
raisons religieuses et pratique les
musulmans ne consomme pas l'arrière des
animaux et cette viande est écoulé dans
les circuits de distribution classiques
non vous confirmerez vous vous nous
direz tout à l'heure le reste de la
viande souvent et on nous l'avait dit
d'ailleurs donc dans certaines auditions
d'accord alors mais malgré tout
certaines certaines bêtes abattues
rituellement qui ne sont pas utilisés
dans la nourriture halal sont écoulés
dans les circuits de distribution
classiques sans aucune mention
particulière concernant la possibilité
d'indiquer l'origine rituel des animaux
sur les barquettes de viande on peut
lire alors je vais citer le site
internet
alcante la filière juive je cite à la
filière juive va souffrir de cette
mesure
tout comme certains organismes de
certification musulmans
qui ont entretenu avec les industriels
une opacité sur la viande qu'il certifie
les juifs parce que la plus grande
partie des carcasses des bêtes cacher
pas se passe dans le circuit
traditionnel et certains organismes de
certification musulmans parce qu'ils ont
noué des partenariats économiques sur le
laxisme et la perte permissivité à
l'égard de pratiques islamiquement
inacceptable alors vous me direz ce que
vous pensez de ce qu'on peut trouver sur
les sites internet de ce genre vous êtes
comme nous très attaché à la liberté de
conscience en tant que religieux c'est
une évidence dès lors êtes vous
favorable à ce que les consommateurs
soient clairement informés sur l'origine
rituels ou non de la viande qu'ils
consomment
en d'autres termes est-ce que vous
trouvez normal que l'on accorde ce droit
aux consommateurs musulmans finalement
d'avoir une étiquette halal sur des
aliments mais pas aux autres
consommateurs selon vous cette
différence de traitement met-elle pas de
nature à vraiment stigmatiser les
musulmans
aux yeux du reste de la population et du
coup aujourd'hui on ressent quand même
une montée du racisme et je m'insurge
contre cette montée du racisme et je
pense que tout ce qui tend à la
transparence peut permettre justement de
lutter contre une montée de certains et
certaines extrême alimenté par un
terreau bien propice en ce moment de
nombreux pays musulmans ont accepté
l'étourdissement préalable des animaux
avant leur abattage alors je voudrais
savoir
êtes vous favorable ou non à cette
étourdissements et pourquoi
alors dans quel ordre voulez-vous
répondre monsieur madame la présidente
madame le rapporteur ses administrateurs
sénateurs
permettez-moi d'abord de faire quelques
commentaires compte à l'intervention de
madame le rapporteur j'ai noté avec
satisfaction mais je ne m'attendais pas
au contraire à ce que vous réaffirmer le
principe de liberté de conscience et et
votre attachement à ce principe comme le
sont également
vous avez une humeur et un certain
nombre de questions qu'il faudrait
peut-être prendre une après l'autre un
heureux mes collègues sont tout de suite
intervenus sur une question précise sur
le fait que la bête est ce qu'il est
consommable par les musulmans y ait des
partis qui ne sont pas console qui sont
mis dans le circuit en standard ou
classique d'abord laquelle sur cette
question c'est clair la bête et conserve
en entier chez les musulmans il n'y a
pas de parti qui n'est pas consommables
dans la bête sur d'autres points
sur la question de deux
d'étourdissements je ne sais pas trop il
faut passer par sur la question du
tourisme ans le conseil français du
culte musulman depuis 2008 a mis en
place un groupe de réflexion sur sur le
l'abattage rituel de façon générale et
sur la signification halal en
particulier dès 2008 où on a vu se
succéder plusieurs réunions notamment
celle de grenay associe l'animal pour la
préparation de règlement intérieur de la
règlement européen de 2009 et dans
toutes ses réunions le conseil français
de culte musulman avait participé avec
le consistoire israélite sur les
discussions
notamment qui portait qui portait
notamment sur le sur le l'étourdissement
ce que nous avons toujours soutenu c'est
que les façon générale dont la tradition
musulmane
vous pouvez toujours trouver des avis
émanant d'un certain nombre de personnes
religieuses qui peuvent dire que
l'étourdissement peut être acceptée
aussi peut être une lecture
mais cet avis est tout à fait
minoritaire ultra-minoritaire là la
position officielle des écoles
juridiques musulmane en tout cas les
quatre voire les cinq si on ajoute les
chiites sont unanimes sur la question de
l'interdît semant les conditions
préalables où on était morte que ce soit
en termes terme ou au préalable ils ne
sont pas année n'est pas compatible avec
l'abattage rituel
en quelques sortes l'abattage rituel
musulman ne se séparent pratiquement pas
de l'abattage rituel juif sauf sur un
certain nombre de points de détails qui
restent à la marche
c'est le même type d'abattage peut
discuter sur des points techniques sur
la le degré de rotation de l'animal
lorsqu'il faut l'abattre est-ce que ce
qu'il faut le mettre à 90° 880 des
questions de cette nature là mais pas
sur le ce qui fait l'essence et de
l'abattage rituel à savoir la question
tourisme en sur le maintenant vous
pouvez effectivement trouvé un certain
nombre de deux organismes qu'ils disent
ou qui font dire que le pays tel pays
musulmans autorise impose
étourdissements en général en général
s'il s'agit plutôt d'organismes de
certification ou des organismes de
production de viande qui prennent une
position qui leur est propre mais qu'ils
n'auraient ils auraient des difficultés
à défendre devant les consommateurs
musulmans
il suffit d'aller faire un tour sur les
quelques forums internet du moyen-orient
ou du proche orient où dans le monde
musulman de façon générale en inde au
pakistan
lorsqu'on voit quelques fois des
questions c'est arras est intéressé
pourquoi ce genre de questions lorsqu'on
entend dire que
en france l'immense majorité de la
viande est étourdi tout de suite on a
des appels au boycott de la viande
française etc
et je pense que on rendra pas service ni
aux professionnels ni aux producteurs ni
à l'économie que de dire que la fion la
viande venant de france est étourdi donc
non conformes au rituel musulman
nous avons souvent communiqué dans ce
sens là parce que nous faisons confiance
à nos professionnels à nos organes
certification halal et nous souhaitons
pas que cette filière soit ébranlée par
ce type de déclaration c'est à dire de
dire que l'étourdissement est acceptée
dont le en france et que tu ta viande
que vous consommez qui s'est enfui halal
est en fête
étourdi alors concernant le j'avais dit
que il n'ya pas de versets coraniques
qui stipule je ne sais pas d'où vous
avez eu cette référence parce que en
tant que rapporteur du sénat vous je
pense vous n'êtes pas habilité à aa à
faire l'exégèse du coran de coop vous
donnez une source de votre de votre de
votre annonce
mais je peux vous dire que les cinq
écoles juridiques musulmans qui sont
reconnues
cette notoriété incontestable sont
toutes sur la même ligne et
l'étourdissement n'est pas admissible
maintenant sur les questions de
l'étourdissement post mortem est ce que
si on va au delà des tests détectent
pouvait dire que les ces textes là ils
peuvent être contextualiser dans un
contexte français particuliers et donc
pourquoi pas aller vers
l'assouplissement des règles de culte
musulman pour répondre à des exigences
tout simplement je juge attire votre
attention sur deux points le premier
c'est que partons déjà du principe de
respect de la conscience et de la
liberté religieuse
le fait d'imposer à aux musulmans des
conditions qui finalement rendre et
l'abattage rituel comme un abattage
standard parce que après je verrai plus
de différence entre l'abattage rituel et
l'abattage standard si vous mettez
l'étourdissement la leur imposer cela ça
va automatiquement à l'encontre de du
principe de liberté religieuse
deuxième point puisque tout ce qui va
être demandé aux musulmans
s'il n'est pas appliquée à la communauté
juive de france risque d'être
contre-productif et générateur de
frustration voire de sentiment d'être
traités à d'une façon différenciée par
rapport à la county vu de france
je pense que si demain vous dites que
les musulmans acceptent l'étourdissement
post mortem alors que les juifs ne
l'acceptent pas et que les consommateurs
musulmans vont se dire encore voilà la
république qui veut faire la différence
entre ses citoyens sur la question de
sur la question de deux parties de lui
partie importante de viande estampillé à
la qui se retrouvent dans l'est dans les
circuits et standard je ne pourrais pas
vous contredire sur ce la page et aucun
chiffre / / / / ce genre de questions
par contre je dois vous dire tout
simplement que le cfcm effectivement
qu'on l'avait rappelé dès 2003 elle
était dans ses prérogatives dans sa
mission de vous d'essayer d'organiser le
halal nous avons produit un document qui
reste un document de travail charte
halal du cfcm dont j'ai une coupe ici
que nous avons pas pu valider pour la
simple raison que je vais citer tout de
suite
on savait la création du cfcm elle a eu
lieu en 2003 en 2008 il ya eu quelques
difficultés à renouveler ses instances
parce que le règlement électoral était
contestée et qu'il fait qu' il y avait
des voix qui s'élevaient pour réformer
le cfcm dont son mode électoral pour ce
mois de gouvernance c'est que nous avons
c'est ce que nous avons commencé à faire
dès 2008 et je vous annonce qu'on
l'avait déjà en temps
le 23 février dernier les statuts du
cfcm ont été réformés et nouveau
règlement électoral a été adopté et sûrs
et donc de nouvelles élections
prochainement pour instaurer une
nouvelle monture du cfcm
nous espérons qu'avec cette nouvelle
monture le dossier de halal deux cas la
charte halal qui était ajournée mais le
travail était pratiquement finalisé
puisse être validée très rapidement
comme on vient de le faire sur le
calendrier lunaire où il ya une décision
du conseil français du culte musulman
c'est un dossier important qu'on a pu
achever parce que autour de la table il
y avait l essentiel des composants du
csm
donc je m'arrête là peut-être il y aura
forcément des laits mes collègues
complètement sur d'autres questions
oui mais adama président bonjour
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
je je je suis dans la conversion de
monsieur le président concernant
l'établissement l'abattage maintenant on
passe au tonnage qu'est ce qui était dit
abattus sans étourdissement ou avec
l'établissement
nous on n'a aucune chiffres officiels à
vos communiqués seulement les
estimations et ce sont pas des
statistiques sont des estimations de
l'intérieur qui dit que sur le 1 million
600 mille tonnes qui sont abattues en
france il y aurait 14 % qui serait de
l'abattage rituel
alors quand on dit rituel n'a pas du
halal et ducasse a donc on n'a pas le
pourcentage de ses 14 % qui dédié au
halal concernant l'import qui est
importé qui rentrent en france sous le
label
rituel toujours halal ou casher ça
représente à peu près 21
21 pour cent soixante huit mille tonnes
et on va tout de suite de ce que disait
maintenant la fois concernant le cette
histoire de perse de consommateurs qui
ne peuvent pas savoir si cette viande a
été abattue de façon rituelle ou pas
pourquoi c'était le problème la question
qui était posée l'histoire de
l'étiquetage
mais si l'étiquetage est imposée en
france les les produits par les
carcasses qui vient de les autres pays
de la communauté qui ne sont pas soumis
à cet étiquetage
comment peut-on faire la différence
entre une ici en france et c'est qu'à
communiquer le un quart d'heure dans son
mars 2012 qui disait que sa porte et je
le cite ce nouveau dispositif continuera
ainsi un handicap à la compétitivité de
la filière viande française
si jamais les viandes importées en donne
une open pour être issu d'abattages unis
resteront non étiquetés comme tels
générant ainsi une distorsion de
concurrence
là aussi il y a quelque chose à faire
entre ce qui est importé équipe qui a
battu soirée tuellement mais qui n'est
pas éthique y est donc le consommateur
français ne peut pas savoir
même si ce que vous disiez à l'institut
tout à l'heure le surplus clients en
abattage rituel
je pense qu'il ya une confusion tout à
l'heure que les abats s'est passé les
juifs plutôt que les constantes par lots
palau donc s'il y a un surplus cette
viande qui va dans le circuit
traditionnel qui 2 qui devait être
édictées qui ne l'est pas alors
justement comme disait monsieur le
président seul en amant ou
l'établissement est strictement
interdite mieux au préalable ni
passeport comme pourrait peut-être un
jour faire la différence
dolan monsieur j'ai une question à vous
poser vous avez parlé de 14 % du tonnage
abattu en france selon la méthode
rituels et vous avez parlé de 21 % des
importations 21% par rapport à quelle
tonnage 21% ville et 21% et
d'importation un d'importation portant à
importer en france
oui mais par rapport à kehl à quel
tonnage de consommation as à 521 1521
hamilton merci c'est bon oui madame et
chocolat vous nous dites que vous ne
connaissez pas les chiffres de
l'abattage rituel en france et vous vous
référer aux chiffres de 14% d'interbev
les abattoirs abattant rituel en
fonction de commande et ils n'ont pas le
droit d'abattre autrement c'est le
second la prochains jours
c'est intéressant non seulement il va y
avoir cette loi qui va être imposé
c'est déjà le cas ils sont déjà obligés
d'abattre en fonction donc c'est tout
connaissez-vous les le monde c'est cette
année là ça a commencé il ya un ou deux
mois mais ce qui est encore longue
encore plus c'est que les sacrificateurs
maintenant qu'ils vont également devoir
subir une formation pour la protection
des animaux le bien-être de l'animal et
c est cette ce qu'on appelle un
certificat de compétences qui leur sera
délivrée par le ministère de
l'agriculture et qui doivent sur cette
formation avant la fin de cette année
d'où le
la réponse à votre question que toute
commande dans l'abattage rituel doit
être au préalable soumis
à la préfecture qui doit partir à
l'abattoir et qui lui doit battre le
tonnage demande est propice pour éviter
justement que le surplus passe dans les
circuits traditionnels
mais là c'est encore mettre les des
abattoirs en très grande difficulté
pourquoi parce que l'abattage rituel
il y a des règles à suivre
c'est soit la première plage horaire
parce que toutes les salles sont propres
le récit âgées la ligne d'horizon assez
ses pieds les chambres froides dans
lequel il doit doivent être mis les
stocker les les carcasses même pas si on
apporte à l'abattoir que oui qu'il doit
abattre
dans l'exemple des centaines de jb deux
albums à s'expliquer ils vont en avoir
pour une heure ou deux là
ensuite il doit repasser à leur système
de battage n'aura donc pas de piège pas
de
ça va leur compliquait énormément la
tâche
bon voilà la valeur qui s'adapte je
comprends pas vous êtes en train de nous
dire que je comprends pas là c'est
pourquoi c'est compliqué pour l'abattoir
ce débat nous l'avons le revenu
effectivement par ailleurs notamment au
niveau de l'europe puisque nous avons
participé à des à des travaux dans ce
dans ce domaine d'âge sur cette question
et là nous étions avec la communauté
juive ensemble et je ne regarde qu'elle
ne soit pas là aujourd'hui parce que non
mais ce que je veux dire non mais nous
aurions souhaité contenu qu'on parle que
l'abattage rituel nous parle pas de
l'abattage musulmans ou de l'abattage
juifs on parle davantage rituelle danse
dans sa globalité et lund dans tout
l'est dans toutes les réunions que nous
avons eues nous étions je suis encore
montrer qu'effectivement il n'y avait
pas de différence et qu'à ce titre là et
qu'à ce titre leur nous devions répondre
ensemble de 7,2 des problèmes que posent
l'abattage rituel en france ce ne sont
pas ce ne sont pas simplement les
musulmans qui ont des problèmes
aujourd'hui content quand on le comprend
on regarde quand on compte quand on
regarde on autres avait au travers de ce
que représente aujourd'hui le annales
prison puisque ce sur ce que je connais
le mieux
ces 5 milliard d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires qui se fait qui était seul
selon une étude qui a été fait par le
cabinet solis
je pense que c'est aussi c'est aussi ce
côté là qu'il va falloir que nous étions
pas sur le côté simplement nous autres
nous sommes aussi qu' aussi sensible que
vous que que les représentants du père
présentant de la nation au niveau au
niveau du bien-être animal aux opposants
sont aussi responsables et nous sommes
aussi sensible que ce côté là je pense
que il faut que nous puissions réfléchir
ensemble madame la présidente sur
comment aujourd'hui quand qu'on en
finisse parce que à toutes les
législatures depuis depuis des années le
halal est remis en question la
stigmatisation est permanente et ont
utilisé souligné madame rapporteur que
aujourd'hui
le notamment le halal est stigmatisée
amy est mis en évidence à chacune des
faucons long terme il faut qu'on trouve
une solution aujourd'hui il me semble je
rencontre que votre commission
aujourd'hui prennent en prennent en
compte ce problème là pour que nous
puissions trouver les solutions et les
solutions ce sont ce sont 5 millions de
musulmans en france sur lequel il va
falloir compter
il y à il y à il ya aujourd'hui plus de
plus de 2500 mosquée en francs en france
qui est qui qui active et qui sont qui
sont présentes
il faut tous ces éléments là tous ces
éléments il faut que la représentation
nationale en tiennent compte
et s'il n'y a pas que les musulmans il
ya les éleveurs il y a les abattoirs il
y a les industriels il ya tout tout tout
tout tout une image une panoplie une
panoplie de deux métiers qui entrent en
ligne de compte qui sont concernés par
le palois il faut à mon sens je
j'entends tout jeu des musulmans sont
pas des babas le problème de l'abattage
rituel et le traitement dans le courant
de ce que peut être le seul elle l'a
l'objet sacrificielle et la façon de le
prêter et vérité blanc si malgré ce
qu'on peut dire il est traité de façon
le l'animal doit être traitée traités
avec respect et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui nous nous souhaitons que
votre votre votre commission puisse
prendre des initiatives dans ce domaine
mais aussi prendre conscience que les
musulmans sont des citoyens français et
qu'à ce titre ils ont le même droit que
vous l'avez souligné madame le
rapporteur tout à l'heure que nous
étions que la liberté de conscience
existe et coule à respecter et j'en suis
très heureux je suis je suis fier d'être
d'être assez à ce niveau là non mais là
dessus soyez rassurés je le mans elles
doivent l'être
je sais je je sais que je ne peux pas
cacher je sais connaît de koné d'accord
berry vous espère que vous leur ligne
mais simplement il faut avancer que nous
trouvions les éléments nécessaires et
que votre commission puisse dans un
cadre global puisque 7 7 7 entre votre
commission n'est pas la commission
la viande viande halal notre mission
monsieur et je vous remercie de l'avoir
rappelé c'est une mission qui porte sur
les productions sur l'abattage et la
transformation et la commercialisation
et nous n'ignorons rien ni du nombre de
personnes musulmanes susceptibles de
consommer de la viande halal pour ce qui
vous concerne et des populations qui
consomment de la viande casher
nous n'ignorons je ne savais pas quelle
était l'ampleur du montant du chiffre
d'affaires 5 milliards d'euros vous
venez de lire je me vous remercie de le
préciser nous savons aussi que ça
représente des emplois nous savons aussi
qu'il y a dans la société française des
interrogations sur des méthodes qui ne
serait pas je dis bien qu'il ne serait
pas de leur point de vue respectueuse
des souffrances animales évitables vous
connaissez la législation européenne je
vous y avez travaillé nous le savons
donc tout cela maintenant il faut
essayer de concilier effectivement des
points de vue tout en respectant et j'y
tiens tout particulièrement la liberté
de conscience et de culte qui est
reconnu par la constitution française
voilà donc nous avons le devoir dans
cette mission de vous interroger de
prendre en compte vos réponses et nous
devrons faire avec les différentes
réponses qui nous sont fournies par
toutes les associations interprofessions
et c est y compris par vous même
nous devrons faire une synthèse avouez
que ce n'est pas facile je pense la
question que vous avez posé sur sur le
tonnage dont qui vous a dit clairement
que
nicolas que le tonnage de point de vue
strictement organismes religieux n'ont
aucun moyen de collecter les
informations concernant la production de
chaque établissement d'abattage
il n'y a pas un registre centralisé chez
les musulmans qui indique que tant de
commande a été faite dentelle out à
l'abattoir seul et professionnel peut
vous transmettre les informations que
les concernant c'est une collecte cause
devait faire auprès de tous les
producteurs de chaka chaque
établissement d'abattage
il a effectivement si registre qui peut
vous fournir c'est le tonnage mais les
musulmans eux mêmes ne peut même pas
demander à un établissement d'abattage
de leur fournir le tournage qu'il fait
pour quelles raisons à quel titre ils
sont pas ils sont passés ils ont pas
cette compétence sur la question
l'étiquetage jury national qui sont
étiquetage est tout à fait vrai que le
consommateur a la liberté effectivement
a le droit le droit de de savoir ce
qu'ils consomment
il a le droit à une information complète
et fiable
l'interrogation que nous nous posons ce
quel type d'informations l'animal le pas
dans le sio sur sur l'animal le
consommateur a besoin
quel type d'information a besoin d'avoir
ce qu'on pourrait se poser la question
sur sur la nourriture de l'animal c'est
sûr comment il se nourrit qu'on met les
transporter après on peut se poser d'ici
laquelle la question sur comment il est
traité et la question de l'abattage son
n'est qu'une question parmi d'autres
c'est une information parmi d'autres
maintenant sur le mode d'abattage qu'est
ce qu'on va mettre comme information et
tour dit ne pas y tour dit ça c'est une
proposition qui a été faite
quelquefois on a même entendu parler
insensibiliser non sonos qui n'est pas
sensibilisés et lui est et tué à vif
il ya plusieurs plusieurs formulations
qui sont possibles simplement nous en
dire que les mêmes les musulmans le
culte musulman n'est pas contre le fait
d'apporter aux consommateurs
l'information dont il a besoin
simplement il faut d'abord prouver la
pertinence
ou l'importance dans le degré où les
critères de l'information qu'il doit que
le consommateur devrait avoir quel est
le mode d'abattage à quel moment il est
donc en aucun emplacement il est parce
que on n'a pas toutes les informations
sur les produits aujourd'hui consommée
ce n'est pas la seule information qui
manquent sur une viande
lorsqu'on va l'acheter vous regarde donc
on pourrait effectivement si on si on
prouve que le fait de savoir le mode
d'abattage est une information
importante et primordiale pour le
consommateur et qu'il ait décidé
finalement de la donner après il
faudrait vient il faut il faut discuter
sur la forme de cette qu'elle va prendre
la forme de cette information par par
coupable c'est parce qu'il ya une
différence énorme entre dire un animal
tué ou abattus avec étourdissement sans
étourdissement
parce que s'il faut aller jusqu'au bout
il faut dire avec avec étourdissement
avec quels types d' étourdissements avec
un pistolet avec un pistolet à tige
perforantes avec asphyxiés par le gaz ou
électro que électrocuté par parle donc
il faut il faut il faut préciser parce
que si vous parlez de souffrance animale
nous on dit que si le culte musulman et
contre étourdissements il ya une raison
simple une seule raison c'est d'éviter
d'infliger à l'animal une souffrance
supplémentaire
nous considérons que l'étourdissement
est une souffrance infligée à l'animal
du faso inutile c'est notre conviction
vous pouvez ne pas la partager ils sont
convaincus que la malle à la façon dont
les allées musulmans tuer les juifs
tuent les années l'animal est beaucoup
plus respectueuse de son bien-être que
l'abattage standard peut être contesté
sur cette conviction
c'est ce qu'a fait le droit il ya des
études concernant la souffrance animale
qui sont très partagés d'ailleurs vous
pouvez vous allez prouver de ceux qui
défendent l'abattage standard d'une
façon farouche avec les arguments que je
me suicide ne sous estime pas vous avez
aussi ceux qui défendent l'abattage
rituel avec des arguments qu'il faut pas
sous-estimer non plus donc nous sommes
prêts nous sommes preneurs de d'études
faites sur la souffrance animale feu
des études sérieuses impartiale sur la
souffrance animale et yeux des deux
côtés des études scientifiques qui
prouvent que tu animal s'il n'est pas
étourdi mais parfois jusqu'à 14 minutes
pour perdre conscience donc perdre la
sensibilité je collais les études il y
en a des doutes et des télés sorte
vous avez des études de la religion et
la science
tout à fait tout à fait je parle je
parle de la sur l'abattage rituel avec
des des scientifiques qui se sont
penchés sur la question de la souffrance
animale mais je dois vous dire que si
les musulmans étaient si les musulmans
étaient sûrs que l'abattage standard et
et faisait souffrir le mois - l'animal
les musulmans auraient choisi l'abattage
standard
parce que la seule ce qui ce qui est ce
qui fonde notre conviction c'est le fait
que l'abattage standard fait souffrir
l'animal davantage tout à l'heure vous
partager comme nous la clause de
conscience qui est d'ailleurs inscrite
dans la constitution et là dessus
personne ne revient dessus mais du coup
les musulmans voix vont pouvoir voir
écrit halal donc tué selon le rite the
rite religieux sur la viande mais les
autres du coup ou si je ne suis pas
musulmane je vais acheter une viande qui
est peut-être tué selon un rite qui
n'est pas le mien est donc vous ne
trouvez pas que cette clause de
conscience devrait être juste et
équitable
si vous permettez je vais réagir sur
d'abord on parle de l'abattage nous
parle pas de sacrificateurs viendra qui
va venir
mais tout d'abord tout d'abord sur la
souffrance souffrance de l'animal
les textes sont clairs l'islam des
hadiths du prophète nous rappelle
quelles sont les conditions pour abattre
des fois nous sommes nous quand on va
visiter des abattoirs où nous sommes
effrayés de voir des mauvaises
conditions
l'animal ne doit pas voir le titre en
champ doit être ne doit pas de visite
ils filent et il faudrait d'abord
données d'un seul coup vous qu'il n'y
ait pas ailleurs en aller retour et il
faudrait qu'il faudrait que il faudrait
que le coûteux soit bien aiguisé ne pas
faire souffrir et souffrir ce faire la
bête que monsieur le président du cfcm
vous a rappelé aussi les conditions de
transport des fois mon temps comme
citoyens simples citoyens responsables
musulmans
des fois quand je vois les accusations
vous avez parlé madame du montée du
racisme at on fait souvent à chaque
combat électoral
l'abattage rituel musulman et remirez
remis en cause on essaye de nous montrer
deux doigts c'est la stigmatisation
si la dernière fois la dernière fois il
a fallu il a fallu que ce soit ce soit
le l'abattage rituel juif qu'ils soient
remis en cause par un premier ministre
que nous avons été encore rappelé à dire
écoutez je reviens sur ma décision et
des musulmans ils étaient invités à
rencontrer monsieur monsieur mais jamais
je pose la question j'ai droit de la
pose et si si c'était juste l'abattage
rituel musulman aurait été mis en cause
est ce que le premier ministre nous
aurait ouvert la porte il a fallu et il
a fallu que ce soit la communauté juive
à monter au créneau et seulement nous
avons été et il ya certains partis
politiques qui ont qui ont utilisé
l'abattage rituel et je vous remercie de
l'avoir de l'avoir dit d'une manière
très petit les sites est clair
maintenant vous vous avez parlé de
laxisme dans l'axé le laxisme et que le
consommateur musulman doit
vous avez dit que vous avez un ami très
pratiquants et ce qu'ils voudraient être
rassurés moi je suis aussi pratiquant et
je suis rassuré je vous assure madame
moi lorsque je vais à carrefour et que
je trouve la viande qui est contrôlé par
une institution reconnue telle que la
mosquée même si c'est par la mosquée
d'evry
c'est la mosquée de lyon qui contrôlent
avec un piquetage et qui a été une
traçabilité avec avec ce qu'on appelle
les outils de l'information
l'informatique et des fois nous notons
correspondent à une descente dans les
abattoirs on voit comment comment les
carcasses ont commencé traçabilité fait
je suis rassuré lorsque je vais
aujourd'hui dans un grand supermarché et
que je trouve une viande qui est mais en
barquettes et qu'il n'y a pas eu de
formation en chemin je l'achète et
j'achète devant tous les musulmans à qui
je fais confiance à qui me voient que
qu'on se consommer je vous assure me
donne je connais aussi des amis non
musulmans qui vient à la mosquée d'evry
donc nous avons une boucherie qui ne
sont pas musulmans et qui achètent de la
viande
ils savent que cette danse est dans
cette boucherie il ya de la viande je
coche quand je vais aussi dans les
magasins discount jeu je vois aussi des
non musulmans se précipiter sur de la
viande essai marqué à l'aise tout
simplement parce qu'il est au bon marché
bon marché aujourd'hui le ll n'est pas
plus cher que l'avion traditionnel
traditionnelle et si tu mets pas quand
je suis d'accord avec vous et nous
sommes tous d'accord lorsqu'on nous
disons que la liberté conscience on ne
doit pas imposer à la halle à des non
musulmans de consommer de consommer à
l'aise et je comprends le souci de
certains partis politiques qui veulent
qui veut qu'ils veulent respecter
respecter même si les mêmes s'ils sont
extrêmement bien qu'ils peuvent
pt 7 cette liberté de choix de choisir
mais en même temps je ne veux pas comme
que comment pose à moi en tant que
citoyen de d'être victime de ce qu'on
appelle le double double double mesure
donc des coûts et et je je je je sais
aussi vous me permettez le laxisme c'est
vrai aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui tout le monde peut se
prétendre vous l'avez même dit se
prétendre et ce autoproclamé celui qui
qui contrôlent que 4 700
eh bien nous nous demander le cfcm nous
aussi nous demandons qu'il y ait qu il y
ait un tri dans dans ce monde du à
l'aide
je vais même des rocheuses les bacs les
clés aujourd'hui une exagération de
l'accomplir syndicales l on peut aller
on parlait dans l'est dans lé nord
chlore poisson c'est machiavel dessus
vous voyez donc qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire justement sur ces
organismes de certification et kehl
comment dire comment s'est organisé
jusqu à l écoute conséquent cela
seulement sur les organisent cet index
est organisée aujourd'hui on connaît
aujourd'hui on connaît les dont on
connaît les
c'est par exemple je vous donne
l'exemple la mosquée de paris la mosquée
d'evry la mosquée de lyon
ils ont un système de contrôle et c'est
ce sont des institutions et sur
l'étiquetage
il y a le numéro de téléphone de ses
mosquées il ay ay ay ay ay topping de
ces mosquées
aujourd'hui je vous pouvez aller dans un
magasin et vous allez trouver par
exemple je suis allé dans un magasin
j'ai trouvé zakia halal ou alors telle
quelle société allèles oui il faudrait
arriver c'est nous sommes demandeurs
nous sommes demandeurs qu'il y ait une
réglementation de dual elle est avec
avec avec un contrôle d'une manière
efficace pour pour assurer pour rassurer
le consommateur pour assurer le
consommateur lui été agréé par les
autorités
nissan a l'air intérieur pour agréer
simplement les sacrificateurs voilà et
si on continue dans le texte pour
organiser le marché alors aujourd'hui
d'encaisser trois moustiques qui ont
cure mis en place l'agrément des 58 14
et la mise en place d'une certification
cette certification je pense que c'est
la plus grande la plus grande qu on
dirait
lacoudre partie est certifié par ces
trois mosquées ensuite il ya un certain
nombre une vingtaine à peu près
d'organismes qui sont constitués
d'assaut pour l'association
vous avez même veritas qui fait de la
certification halal
oui ce côté que ce petit peu de la
certification halal il y à des désastres
jeudi à des associations il y avait des
sociétés qui sommeille qui font de la
certification
donc ce que 10ème se déroule c'est qu'il
y a au delà donc de la d2 c'est trop
long ce qu'il ya un certain nombre
d'autres associations d'autres
structures qui font de la certification
ceci est dû à quoi sont généralement les
entreprises qui veulent s'affranchir
d'un du halal en trouvant en trois ans
quelqu'un et qu'il ordonnera sont cachés
ou sa signature ou quelque chose de ce
genre là pour pouvoir conduire un
musulman tu vois c'est monsieur untel
qui m'a dit qu'ils me bats c'est c'est
la seule association la petite mosquée
du quartier la bac qui fait qu père la
certification
il y a aussi ce n'est pas simplement la
botte de des structures qu'on connaît
c'est aussi le système le système
économique notamment un certain nombre
d'industriels qui veulent et qui
encourage la création de sept de ses
structures
il se développe d'autre part qu est-ce
qu on peut les éviter non parce que nous
sommes dans un système de libre
les livres encore la concurrence mais de
la liberté de la liberté du commerce on
ne peut pas interdire à telle
association est l organisme se faire de
la même chose ici du cfcm a parlé tout à
l'heure c'est la mise en place d'une
d'une charte qui permettent
effectivement de donner les agréments
les agréent de de dire ce qu'est une
viande halak dire comment lors comment
l'obtient avec quels moyens
je pense que ça c'est un élément
important il va falloir qui va régler et
je dirais en grande partie ça en somme
la charte dont vous parlez et qui est en
cours d'élaboration si je comprends bien
oui doit déboucher sur un cahier des
charges qui serait imposée à chaque
organisme certificateur prétend être
certificateur que tu as fait d'affairé
qu'avec tes sous contrôle les trois
mosquées qui ont été cités je peux vous
décrire brièvement le la conception que
nous avons de l'organisation de la
ratification
il ya effectivement le cas ils cherchent
qui définit ce que c'est le halal ce que
ce ce que c'est l'abattage selon le rite
musulman donc tout c'est tous ces points
là ils seront donc dont le seul parti
qui charge sur notre parti de cette
charte et y aurait ce qu'on n'entend pas
un organisme de certification
quelles sont les conditions qui sont
requises pour un organisme de
certification
c'est une association 1901 c'est c'est
une société etc
le troisième point le mécanisme qui
permettrait au conseil français de culte
musulman d'agréer des organismes qui
auraient respecté à certaines conditions
leur faire signer le cahier des charges
pour le respecter et ensuite nous avons
imaginé ce qui est déjà prévu dans la
charte
un comité de suivi qui pourrait faire
les audits pour voir si les signataires
donc les organes les organismes de
certification qui sont signataires de la
charte halal et qui sont gars qui sont
engagés à respecter ce cahier est ce qui
le respectent réellement sur le terrain
auquel cas il peut retirer les agréments
tout cas ils vous pouvez avoir un
système de sanction de retrait retrait
d'agrément
donc tout ça c'est s'est décrit la
charte et les on va dire le texte il est
prêt une trentaine de pages
surtout séparation précisé comme je
disais tout à l'heure la seule chose qui
monte qui ne permettait pas de le faire
valider c'est que le conseil français du
culte musulman une institution jeunes
dans le système de gouvernance était
contestée en interne
il fallait d'abord le consolider et le
renforcer le pérenniser pourquoi mettre
de traiter des dossiers qui sont de
cette nature des dossiers qui demande
une large concertation une large
adhésion de toutes les composantes de
l'islam de france
je suis convaincu qu'avec dans les
quelques années à venir
quelques mois à venir ce projet de
charte halal verra le jour
vous avez posé la question sur le
respect la conscience de citoyen qui ne
souhaitent pas consommer halal c'est
leur droit absolu et je nous sommes tout
à fait d'accord sur le fait que si le
consommateur souhaite savoir parce qu'en
réalité on pourrait parler de deux mode
d'abattage
si aujourd'hui il ya une différence
entre l'abattage standard et l'abattage
rituel
parce qu'il était instaurée par la
réglementation européenne qui a
considéré que l'abattage rituel était
une dérogation ce système dérogatoire
fait de façon automatique que l'abattage
rituel et les différencier par rapport à
un partage sonore pour imaginer des
situations où les deux à bata shoe sur
ce mal sont de mode d'abattage qui
peuvent qui se valent donc les produits
issus de ces deux abattage il doit la
salle et les scientifiques ils disent qu
elles en termes de viande interne la
qualité de la viande
il n'y a pas vraiment de différence on
ne peut pas sauter à la différence entre
une viande abattue de façon rituelle ou
pas le consommateur termes de goût au
terme de notre qualité de la viande il
ne pourrait pas sentir la différence
nous sommes nous sommes effectivement
prêts à admettre que le consommateur qui
souhaite savoir à tout prix si cette
viande a été abattue de façon rituelle
ou pas c'est son droit absolu
simplement il faudrait que cette
information soit équitable faudrait pas
qu'à stigmatiser les musulmans les juifs
c'est à dire aux trotteurs autrement dit
talence losc utilisé entre dire qu'il a
une viande est abattu de façon rituelle
non rituel ça peut pas être une
information beaucoup meilleur que de
dire étourdis ou non étourdis sabri
tournis non étourdis dit tout à l'heure
sinon il tord dit non étourdis c'est
pour moi c'est stigmatisant parce que le
théâtre le terme étourdi s'épanouit tour
10 et c'est pas l'étourdissement c'est
un assaut si vous voulez utiliser
utiliser assommage non à ce mal oui mais
tu utiliseras chômage pour les tours 10
sur ce que monsieur mais rhône a dit
tout à l'heure vous aviez peur monsieur
que finalement on stigmatise et et que
parallèlement ça pénalise la filière
viande en france que du coup des gens
n'achètent plus en se disant ouhlala
c'est peut-être tué d'une certaine
manière ou d'une autre
vous avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
meyroune que vous connaissiez plein de
gens qui achetaient des viandes issues
de l'abattage rituel sans aucun problème
ils achètent même du halal moi je suis
convaincu que la transparence n'est pas
du tout la stigmatisation
bien au contraire j'ai le sentiment
qu'au lieu d'entretenir le vivre les uns
à côté des autres
il faut travailler sur le vivre ensemble
et le vivre ensemble c'est la
transparence et la transparence aussi
dans le choix de la consommation si je
veux acheter un gigot qui a été abattu à
la halle je le fais en conscience si je
ne veux pas le faire parce que ma
religion me l'interdît peut-être je le
fais en conscience madame et
heureusement qu'est ce qui faisait les
musulmans on allait on allait chez les
bouchers et juifs à belleville moi je
montais d'evry à belleville chez un juif
et j'ai acheté de la viande lui mais par
contre j'avais la possibilité aussi
d'aller chez un chrétien et de n'acheter
mais je n'ai plus cette possibilité
pourquoi parce que le chrétien et il a
modifié sa manière d'abattre il n'est
plus et n'est plus dans le même dans le
même contexte que moi on tord musulmans
et lorsque lorsque lorsque
lorsque lorsque les bouchers musulmans à
vue à aba à barbès ils ont commencé à à
dire allèles alors que ce n'était pas à
l'aise il était hésitant il était aisé
des fraudeurs et les muses les musulmans
sont des victimes de cette nourriture
nos jours de cette manière d'agir est
très souvent les premiers à l'avoir
dénoncé c'étaient les musulmans
lorsqu'on a commencé sur un solde à
sawgrass organes à s'organiser
nous sommes d'accord il n'y a pas de
divergence on trouve ce que vous dites
est ce que le disant mais seulement si
on fait l'étiquetage il faut que le
fasse pour le traditionnel pour que les
musulmans ne tombe pas aussi à michelin
décroche dans le piège du traditionnel
il faudrait aussi le faire pour le
cacher et dire se cacher et faire et
faire à l'air vous savez ce que je fais
moi la mosquée début et pas très loin
donc de centre commercial je vais faire
mes courses très souvent il ya le halal
à côté et le cacher à côté et très
souvent nous trouvons des viandes
traditionnel pourquoi parce que le
consommateur il est at il lâché de
l'avion traditionnels comme il voit
qu'il n'a passé n'a passé de quoi payer
et voilà déposés dont dont le
compartiment le plus proche et très
souvent on trouve cette viande l'a très
souvent je suis intervient auprès de
l'erc du magasin pour lui dire qu'il
faudrait aussi protégé s'est passé pas
stigmatisant de 10 voilà le cacher exact
voilà le fallait mais voilà le
traditionnel faudrait pas que ce soit
tout simplement pour le manège la
question concernant le
cette histoire l'étiquetage mais la
question devrait être posée aux
professionnels nous on n'est pas contre
qu'elles soient étiquetés c'est pas nous
on a pas à dire aux professionnels le
surplus qui et vous devez les pistes
énoncées un de dire que voilà j'ai
abattu temps il me reste tant il doit
l'étiqueter et doit le faire savoir s'il
doit partir bien à beaucoup de
difficultés à voir les chiffres vous
savez c'est le flou artistique grand
complet au bout dans le bâti si les
professionnels peuvent faire deux choses
non seulement valider la charte du cfcm
la valider les professionnels que le
cfcm puisse à gré des organismes qu'ils
puissent certifier et que toutes les
fédérations profiteurs de
l'agroalimentaire valide ça peut-être
emploi voir quelque chose se profiler
sur la certification halal cantat dans
l'étiquetage
la question se pose aux professionnels
c'est à eux de dire que le surplus va
dans cette vie traditionnel on parle de
2 du halal et d éducation
quant à noël internet me le dise pour
citer leur communiqué du 2 mars 2012 que
si jamais cet étiquetage est appliquée
s'est tenue ce nouveau dispositif
concerne ancien l'handicap à la
compétitivité de la filière française
parce qu'on ne pourra pas étiqueté ceux
qui viennent des autres pays de la
communauté qui n'a pas beaucoup pesé
comment excuser les phrases lundi j'ai
refusé d'aller d'aller contre d'aller
passer une convention avec une société
française qui va abattre
aux pays-bas le risque le risque
d'ailleurs ça a été dit nous notons que
citoyens musulmans responsable de france
on veut on veut promouvoir et encourager
face à cette crise qui nous faut qu'ils
nous frappent et une consommation
française est un produit français
aujourd'hui 21% sont importés mais vous
savez comme moi que c'est un portait
souvent de pays qui interdisent
l'abattage sans étourdissement nouvelle
zélande pour le mouton il est pas
consommé essentiellement par les
musulmans je pense pas que quand vous
parlez du mouton dont elle a déjà
reparti la majeure partie des débats
notamment du loot on est abattu en
france et est consommée est consommée
notamment par les musulmans ce que je
veux dire tout à l'heure vous avez posé
c'est qu'un certain nombre de bauchi de
plus en plus de boucherie traditionnelle
ferment leurs portes
ils sont remplacés par des bouchers à
l'aube dans le quartier on a le quartier
où j'habite
c'est le cas et je vois les petites
télés petite dame toutes les personnes
âgées où elles vont elle va acheter le
même homme du match lorient d'année je
pense que aujourd'hui est ce que la
viande halal quelques telle qu'on n'a
pas lé lé consommables ou pas par là par
la guerre par l'ensemble des biens pas
sur le côté c'est le notaire est ce que
est ce que ce sujet ce poids là je sais
qu'on ne revient pas dessus mais ce que
je veux dire à ce qu'elle est contre
elle et c'était bien consommable qu'elle
est maintenu et même qualité les mêmes
qualités de même qu'elles mêmes qualités
et les mêmes
il est donc à ce titre là pour ce qui le
concerne
vous parlez de l'étiquetage si vous
lisez que pour les musulmans ça me gêne
pas mais qu'est ce qui est vrai pourquoi
parce que nous consommons la bête on
tient
certains professionnels pourquoi se
disent je vais cette bête là je vais
vendre le lavant aux musulmans parce que
c'est une viande coûte pas cher et le
reste j'ai géré clientèle pour et c'est
la clé qui a gardé le traditionnel
malgré ses clients qui restent
traditionnelles celles qui m'avaient qui
n'est pas censé manger de la viande
halal
ces questions là sur des questions que
nous avons sur lesquels nous avons
disputé notamment à la commission
agricole du conseil de bruxelles là bas
et c'était monsieur le foll qui nous
avait reçu à l'époque et qui sur cette
question là aujourd'hui avait avait
avait compris l'intérêt économique que
cela pouvait représenter ne sont pas
contre les musulmans soit parce que
l'eau 2010 pourquoi c'est pas marqué
tous les toutes les équipes à un
contrôle qui disent que c'était que
cette date a été abattue rituellement
comme salle où ça nous rassure mais il y
a le côté économique et le côté aussi de
deux de nos amis juifs mais ça poserait
pas de problème je pense d'avoir un
étiquetage transparent mais claire moi
je voudrais vous permettait
effectivement ce je dirai simplement
l'information qui doit être portée aux
consommateurs elle devrait être
équitable en termes d'information je
pense que ces deux juges je pense la
difficulté n'est pas une et pas il n'est
pas sous-estimer parce que lorsqu'on dit
étourdi non étourdis pour nous n'est pas
on est on est on est contre ce type
d'information parce qu'elle n'est pas
juste le terme étourdi n'est pas le bon
terme
dans ce cas là il faudrait il faudrait
préciser qu est le mode
d'étourdissements non mais qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre alors
comme si vous suivrez si vous voulez
apporter l'information soit sauve au
soin aux cibles possibles la souffrance
animale et dans ce cas là il faut il
faut mettre m par exemple que cette bête
a été a été a été assommée avec une tige
performante perforantes à semer non à
semer à semer ou en précisant le mode le
mot d'étourdissement puisque c'est
important peut-être pour les gens de
savoir si la bête a été étouffée avec du
gaz carbonique dans une chambre à gaz
mais si le terme et leur fait sur autre
chose
c'est peut être électrocutée sicile et
si le l'assommage a été fait avec un
coût de coups parce qu'il peut se
tromper
notre premier tir il rate sa cible et
fin de et puis lorsque la viande est
transformé il faudrait préciser le
pourcentage de la viande pour venant de
de l'abattage classique celle devenue
provenant de l'abattage rituel et donc
on va voir non seulement une étiquette
mais c'est peut être à caillé qui va qui
va accompagner le produit de la filière
viande on n'aurait peut-être pas eu du
cheval qui se serait transformé en
boeufs en voyageant est ce que c'était
et l abattage c'est le mode d'abattage
la cci mais pas le mode d'abattage et de
l'espèce carrément c'est l'espèce qui
n'a pas été contrôlé il ya de la
religion tout ça pour temps pour que
parce que l'eau à l'aide
je faisais moi nous ait jugé le halal a
évité aux musulmans de ne pas consommer
cette viande mais non mais sans problème
il n'y a pas d' amalgame là dessus non
plus je voudrais revenir sur certains
pourtant vous autorisez parfois
l'étourdissement de certaines
de certaines comme on dira de la
volaille par exemple alors pour de
certaines espèces
pourquoi l'autorisé pour certaines
espèces mais pas pour d'autres
je pense que effectivement pour ce qui
concerne le poulet ou la volaille part
il y a il ya certains emplois
l'électronarcose pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que la bête soit calme et du fait
qu'elle se débat dans ce cas ce n'est
plus vendable lorsqu'elle est présente
des ecchymoses sur le donc aujourd'hui
je suis un certain nombre de dents un
certain nombre d'abattoirs il ya
l'utilisation du street art
certaines utilisent utilisé très forte
dose de la bête arrive est très sûrs
d'eux delà du débat du bac bac elle est
déjà morte tant qu'elle est morte de
l'électronarcose de l'électricité
quillan et ensuite elle est abattue dans
certains grande usine avec à l'a6a sont
certaines certains abattoirs utilise une
autre la cause tiré de façon mesurée
permettent lorsque la bête sort de là
avec calme elle est encore vivante
serment et l'a encore vu entre ya des
tests et l'impossibilité de la halle à
sortir de l'enfer un peu d'intérêt donc
et lorsqu'elle arrive sacrificateur elle
ne se débat pas est laid et l'abattage
purple à la cuisse je peut se faire à se
voir donc ça c'est la leçon
c'est le seul c'est un des abattages qui
qui est dit
il existe aujourd'hui en france et sur
lequel certains facteurs et clis et ne
pourrait-on envisager l'étourdissement
de ce type il ya la prétention à la
contention vous allez pour certains
espèces elle va subir deux fois le
notamment pour le boeuf ou le loup bleu
ou le veau ou loulou le bouton donc ils
vont subir première lalalalalala
première comment dirais-je
ils sont assommés
oui et ensuite les donc de quelle façon
la boîte est elle morte
abbas est réversible parce que si on la
laisse par terre elle se relève elle
repart donc on va dire il faut pas
qu'elle soit morte
moi je voudrais revenir quand même sur
des textes que j'ai trouvé alors ne m'en
veuillez pas messieurs je n'analyse pas
du tout le coran ça n'est pas mon rôle
et je sais rester à ma place je tiens à
le dire mais malgré tout je sais lire et
donc je me suis documenté vous ne m'en
voudrez pas et pardon si je vous choque
mais il faut bien à un moment donné
avant c'est un peu alors j'ai trouvé des
textes concernant des fatwas commission
de fatwas égyptienne rendu le 18
décembre 1978 toyer c'est à la fois hier
et avant-hier signé par le cheik jade al
haq alijah d'halak également une autre
fatto à saoudienne 2009 sens 4,77 pardon
alors je cite si l'animal a été abattu
par un pistolet ou par un choc
électrique et que l'animal a été
j'ai pendant qu'il était encore en vie
après avoir reçu le coup sur la tête
alors que sa viande
alors ça vient des licite en raison de
la parole de dieu
ça c'est le premier point ces fatwas
parmi d'autres démontrent que les
autorités religieuses musulmanes
admettent le recours à l'étourdissement
à condition qu'ils ne provoquent pas la
mort de l'animal ça rejoint ce que vous
disiez très justement monsieur j'ai
encore un autre un autre extrait quand
les autorités musulmanes sont plus
larges que certaines autres autorités
puisque l admettent l'étourdissement des
animaux avant la saignée soit par
électronarcose soit par pistolet à la
seule condition que l'animal soit encore
vivant lorsqu'il est saigné donc que son
coeur bat donc est ce que vous ne croyez
pas
messieurs que les autorités religieuses
doivent s'adapter à l'évolution de la
société que toutes les religions doivent
s'adapter à l'évolution de la société
alors j'ai aussi lu alors pardon si je
vous choque mais tant pis des
traductions de mahomet j'ai pas la rade
malheureusement j'aurais rêvé le lire
dieu a prescrit la bonté en toute chose
si vous tuez faites le avec bonté et si
vous saignez un animal faites le avec
bonté
de ce fait les autorités ne s'oppose pas
dans certains pays à l'étourdissement
des animaux à condition que
l'étourdissement ne provoque pas la mort
avant qu'il soit signé afin qu'ils
souffrent moins vous citez des fatwas
qui vont dans le sens de ce que vous
voulez comprendre
bien évidemment non pour vous en citer
c'est normal d'autres qui vont
complètement contre le sens de l'aigle
contre l'étourdissement et là il y en a
plus que ce que vous croyez
et ça je peux vous l'assurer il ya même
des livres d'aidés dernière on vous
donne l'exemple utilisez vous savez dans
le monde
il y à des organismes qu'on appelle le
conseil des sages de la manne points
suivi du halot heide d'indonésie me
prenais des acquis vous prenez ceux des
émirats vous prenez l'arabie
qui aujourd'hui cinq ans aujourd'hui en
train de faire ce qu'on appelle le salon
halal forum malade donc de lundi qui
aura l'année prochaine sa propre norme
et on va voir ça va sortir cette norme
notamment on va sur l'histoire de
l'établissement et de l'ailé de
l'électronarcose se référer aux fatwas
et se référer à sequedin
mais le coran c'est l'interprétation de
serre la main qui leur font dire que
telle chose peut peut être
parmi ces pas de pratiquer mais si on
pouvait l'éviter c'est encore mieux dans
le cast actuelle la seule chose qu'on
peut passer contre éviter cet
établissement
vous savez le lot à bien toutes les
occasions de voler votre vision des
animaux font tout pour que l'on puisse
arriver à ça elle un nom à faire tout le
contraire
donc ça n'arrive pas pourquoi on n'est
pas en vous cite vous pouvez chercher
dans le corps dans les hadiths vous en
trouverez certainement quelques actifs
ans excusez moi qui va le trouver
je vais je crois demander à chacun de ne
pas continuer sur ce domaine religieux
qui n'est pas le sujet de notre mission
si vous permettez je pense je pense que
madame la présidente et à tout à fait on
n'a pas raison de dire que sa sidération
je demande qu'on recentre le débat sur
une question clé celle au nom de la
souffrance de l'animal
vous avez dit tout à l'heure qu'il y
avait des études précises sur la
souffrance de l'animal
en effet il y a un rapport de l'inra qui
fait état de souffrance des animaux au
moment de l'abattage et qui reconnaît
que les souffrances peuvent être causées
par le matador comme on dit
familièrement ou l'électronarcose mais
aussi par l'abattage rituel bien donc
est-ce que vous avez vous des éléments
précis scientifiques qui permettent de
mesurer la souffrance de l'animal de
façon à ce que on essaie
de faire la part des choses entre
vaut-il mieux être étourdis avant ou
étourdi après parce que j'ai
connaissance d'un abattoir où l'on abat
rituellement et où l'on est ourdi dans
les cinq secondes qui suivent
l'égorgement donc ça existe je peux même
vous le site et donc je veux dire par là
je revenons à la à l'objet même de notre
débat c'est à dire la souffrance de
l'animal est elle réelle est elle plus
forte d'un côté que de l'autre et elle
en cela susceptible de provoquer chez le
consommateur un recul voire un refus par
rapport à la consommation d'une viande
qui au retrait sa conscience si nous
permettait je pense que vous avez
recentrer madame président que le débat
sur la souffrance et jules et déjà dit
tout à l'heure vous fait que yahvé fils
il y avait effectivement des études sur
la souffrance animale qui disent
clairement que l'abattage rituel
il fait souffrir - l'abattage que
l'abattage
ce standard d'autres études qu'il faut
qu'il dise le contraire
tout à fait je vous accorde parfaitement
cela et je j'ajoute également que les le
culte musulman est prêt à faire un
recensement de ces études est de faire
la part des choses qu'une qu'une étude
soit soit lancé sur eux une sorte de
comparatifs de ces études qui ont été
faites
parce que j'ai avec des scientifiques
tom et et moi de vous dire que ce soit
le dial réel ou autre il ya eu des
études qui ont été présentés d'autres
qui disent le contraire
c'est cette année c'est un stade c'est
un constat il ya des études qui
défendent l'abattage rituel et des
études qui défendent l'abattage standard
et notamment à l'inra il y avait une
thèse de doctorat qui a été réalisée sur
l'abattage rituel en vous mêmes méthodes
de d'occire on veut parler de la
souffrance animale judicaire dans l'est
dans l'état actuel des choses des études
qui sont faites
on peut pas trancher de façon claire et
de dire que l'abattage rituel fait
souffrir plus l'animal que l'abattage
standard
ça c'est notre conviction et je vous
dirais même plus loi que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure que le seul argument que
qui fait que les musulmans défendent
l'abattage rituel c'est le fait que cet
abattage fait sourire souffrir le moins
animal c'est notre conviction on peut
être contesté sur cette conviction mais
je la seule la seule raison que la
bataille ne se soit fait de cette
manière là c'est pour éviter à l'animal
de ceux de souffrir et le fanny ce que
vous avez cités tout à l'heure il va
dans ce sens la noc faisant d'eux
faisant donc des études concernant
souffrance animale maintenant sur sur
l'aspect je veux dire à un petit à petit
aperçu sur ce qui peut heurter le
consommateur il est vrai que l'abattage
sans étourdissement
lorsqu'il est lorsqu'il ya l'incision
l'animal après même après un certain
temps il va commencer à se débattre il
ya des mouvements ces mouvements les
études kyi qui défend d'abattage rituel
il parle de mouvement inconscient de la
partie la partie 2 qui va sortir la
souffrance et les mortes ce que la peine
de mort encéphalique
il est morte il ya appris à des
mouvements l'air d'un con si
inconscience deux des membres qui bouge
c'est ces mouvements inconscient
permettent à la bête de se vider de son
sens parce que le cerveau une fois il
est la partie consciente et les mortes
la partie inconsciente elle demande aux
autres membres de 2,2 de servir le
cerveau du sang parce qu'il est il n'a
plus d'oxygène
les membres il aux voix il envoie il
envoie le sang comme les deux vanille
sentent ils sont coupés le sont et se
déverse et je dirais lorsque même si la
comparaison il est peut-être mal placé
mais lorsque vous prenez un être humain
mort encéphalique mans et que vous
demandez un de ses proches de venir à
côté et que vous avez ou le médecin a
souhaité de prélever de prélever des
organes sur un corps qui conquit qui
continuent à respirer à voir un être
humain il ya le il ya des mouvements
d'apparence de vie la personne elle est
morte en c'est à l'icm en mai
des apparences de vie la respiration des
et pourtant pourtant le médecin il va et
20 procéder au prélèvement des organes
est ce que vous pouvez dire que cette
personne est en train de souffrir parce
qu'ils aient puisqu'il continue à
respirer donc il va il va souffrir en
prélevant des organes est-ce qu'on suis
d'accord avec vous c'est vrai qu'un
accidenté de la route quel cerveau très
abîmée parfois à son coeur qui bat
encore que ta faveur du coup pourquoi ne
pourrait-on pas utiliser un matador pour
étourdir au préalable un animal
puisqu'il serait encore vivant mais je
vous pose mais je vous dis clairement
que l'étourdissement est une souffrance
supplémentaire qu'on inflige à l'animal
donc on accepte pour cette raison
n'accepte pas qu'ils soient réversibles
au passé elles la question c'est pas la
question de réversibilité joie la
question c'est pas la question de
réversibilité
dès lors que dès lors qu'on compte app
ou qu on assomme l'animal on a fait on
fait souffrir l'animal
tous les syndicats vétérinaire de france
sont favorables à l'abattage avec
étourdissement et les vétérinaires sont
quand même je sais pas l'éviter là qui
font la religion musulmane madame je
joue je vous dire une chose je sens
venir se revenir comme l'a dit madame la
présente sur sur la question de fatwas
il ya une une instance représentative du
culte musulman qui le conseil français
du culte musulman seul habilité à dire
ce qui fait partie de nous disons nous
disons clairement que la position du
conseil français du culte musulman n'a
jamais changé il n'est pas pour
l'étourdissement ni en tennis post
mortem sur ce point là on est comme le
consistoire israélite de la même manière
et je vous ne pensez pas que je pense à
la conscience des gens du coup et je me
dis est ce que les gens s'y prennent
conscience qu'un animal et égorgé qui
peut souffrir pendant ou moins gigoter
pendant 14 minutes
est-ce que vous pensez que ça la rassure
ce consommateur musulman ou non les
consciences évoluent y compris chez les
musulmans les musulmans de france sont
des gens extrêmement ouvert et tolérant
n'est pas me dire le contraire a fait ça
c'est pour cette raison qu'on vous dit
que labatt au risque de me répéter je
pense que nous devons nous considèrent
eux sont convaincus que l'abattage t'es
con
fait il fait souffrir le mois animal ça
sur ce point là vous pouvez pas ne
pouvez vous pouvez apporter la
contredire la contradiction c'est votre
droit à pau retenue n'a pas apporté la
contradiction et dans ce cas là les
misions évolueront je suis désolé ils
disent pas les contradictions vous
permettez on viens de vous le dire
monsieur moussaoui viens de vous dire
qu'il ya des études différentes
là nous les musulmans ne sont prêts avec
ses vétérinaires cesser ces abattoirs et
de faire une étude ensemble non mais n'a
pas été fait ne sais pas c'est pas en
présence de tout le monde
ce sont des spécialistes qui nous ont
dit qu'ils nous ont donné des noms aussi
on ne peut apporter nos spécialistes de
notre choix et vous pouvez apporter
votre vos spéciale de votre choix et
qu'on puisse trouver synthèse le a dit
que vous venez de citer
je sais ce que j'avais commencé puisque
vous m'avez arrêtez vous parlez du
sacrificateur on verra on en parlera à
la fatwa madame monsieur j'ai 2 il est
mort il ya vingt ans ça fait la fête
soit appartient à l'homme à l'imam il a
besoin de trois critères pour qu'il soit
accepté
on va pas rentrer dans ce domaine il a
été contré la été contredite nos nous ce
que nous ce qu'on veut c'est trouver une
solution une solution technique pratique
pour ne pas faire souffrir l'animal zone
nous nous disons l'abattage tel que le
pratique la communauté juive et la
communauté musulmane qui souffrirent -
l'animal le vous de votre côté vous
dites non les pacifiques le 10 mois les
scientifiques le disent non alors les
sur les scientifiques
monsieur moussaoui viens de vous dire
qu'ils sont qui a qui est des
contradictions d' analyse et bien cette
co paul puisque les unit nos années à
venir essayer
essayons de faire ensemble ça permet de
reculer encore la faire je suis aussi
surpris que vous prenez peuple et par
dessus il ya des études qui ont été
faites je pense que vous devrez être
impartiale sur votre présentation des
choses il ya des études scientifiques
les autres y sont six scientifiques vous
pouvez pas les qualifier autrement c'est
tellement j'allais dire que nous allons
inviter en audition les vétérinaires qui
ont travaillé dans sur le rapport de
l'inra en 2009 que si vous avez des
études scientifiques à nous soumettre
nous recevrons également ces personnes
et éventuellement nous les confronterons
parce que c'est peut-être le meilleur
moyen effectivement de savoir s'en aller
au delà effectivement de considération
qui nous qui nous conduirait je crois
dans des voies qui ne sont pas
raisonnables au sens que nous nous ne
maîtrisons pas effectivement
l'aboutissement de ce débat je vous
redonne la parole et je voulais vous
dire que vers dans dix minutes
nous mettrons fin à ce débat et j'ai une
autre question économique à poser
allez-y monsieur que je vais dire
simplement ce que n'était votre micro
kamal capitale depuis tout à l'heure
effectivement le débat a porté sur le
halal et sur l'abattage rituel
est-ce que ça entre dans le cadre d'une
politique générale de la filière viande
ou est-ce que simplement lorsqu'on
écoute madame la dame le rapporteur on
sent qu'il y a on veut aller dans tel
direction c'est celle d'interdire ou de
limiter l'abattage rituel
c'est la question j'aimerais bien à
laquelle il souhaiterait comme réponse
mais je vais lui répondre très
clairement notre mission porte je
voulais dit en introduction sur les
conditions les productions animales
l'abattage et la transformation et la
commercialisation donc l'abattage
comporte non seulement des quantités
des aspects économiques mais aussi des
questions que se pose la société par
rapport à cette question qui émane de la
fraude à la viande de cheval rétablir la
confiance des consommateurs et on ne
peut pas dire que ce ne soit pas à
l'ordre du jour
vous l'avez vous même reconnu et le
climat des élections de la campagne des
élections présidentielles a été assez
révélateur à ce propos donc justement
nous voulons essayer de trouver dans
cette mission l'occasion de mettre à
plat les choses et je pense que ça ça
fait partie je vous remercie à points
que nous devons éclaircir a parlé on a
parlé de la production destinée à la
consommation en france mais est ce que
la pensée à la production à
l'exportation qui représente je pense un
chiffre assez significatives qui est de
2,2 pour l'économie française
oui et c'est que ces exportations se
font en direction de pays arabes
la grande majorité de ces pays qui au
sol notamment les produits français
impose et veulent que la viande la
viande qui est qui est vendu qu'il a
regular est proposée ce soir miroir
conforme alors aujourd'hui
et lorsque l'on voit au travers des
informations dès que nous avons un
certain nombre de pays ont pris
conscience que les viandes qui
consommaient n'étaient pas conformes aux
rituels musulmans et qu'ils imposent
l'arabie saoudite qui pendant longtemps
avaient mangé des produits de chez doux
qui étaient abattus a qu'une machine
l'équité donc aujourd'hui un pause
imposée souhaite que les viandes qu'ils
soient abattus par un sacrificateur dans
l'étang dans les normes prescrites par
la voilà la réalité il faut aussi je
pense puisque vous parlez de la vôtre
votre étude englobe incertain et ces
questions là on aimerait bien aussi que
parler de ces questions là comment
aujourd'hui l'économie française au
travers de mattel pouvoir répondre aux
besoins et à la demande de ces pays mais
nous en sommes tout à fait conscients et
je n'ai pas dit que c'était simplement
donc c'est pour ça que nous voulons
mettre à plat toutes les questions y
compris épineuse qui sont posés à la
fois par la société mais aussi par les
filières de production et les filières
de commercialisation et je pense qu en
particulier la filière de
commercialisation de la viande en france
aurait intérêt à être plus transparents
sur les surplus de viande abattue
rituellement et qui sont ces je pense
reconnu par tous destinés à
l'alimentation traditionnelle
non c'est non rituel non cultuelle bon
donc je crois que là-dessus on n'a pas
l'intention de faire l'économie de mise
à plat là aussi dans la présidente
nous avons conscience ou musulmans nous
voulons pas imposer aux autres cieux
concitoyens notre manière de vivre
d'autres manières de pratiquer notre
religion
larousse nous avons sept cette prise de
conscience
mais en même temps il faudrait pas nous
accuser nous que nous mettons l'élu mais
une partie de la viande qui n'est pas
consommée par tel ou tel ou lever la
confusion tout à l'heure on a commencé
par la confusion les musulmans ne
mangent pas une partie nous ce qu'on
demande
il y à un certain nombre de tonnage
parents qui est consommé par les
musulmans eh bien faisons en sorte que
ce tonnage pas plus pour que nous ne
puissions pas l'on pose d'imposer à
d'autres concitoyens pour qu telle ou
telle partie des politiques ne puissent
pas brûler le sas son drapeau pour dire
voilà les musulmans nous impose quoi que
ce soit à aucun moment nous voulons
imposer le poser des tice chez nous est
interdit aux liestal on n'a pas à
imposer
elle est interdite par l'islam le texte
n'est pas là pour parler des plex
nous les musulmans nous n'imposons pas
le prosélytisme nous ce qu'on veut c'est
de consommer et des manières nous on est
d'accord avec vous dire il ya tant de
tonnes de tonnage pour les pour les cinq
mille musulmans
eh bien on va on va abattre ce tonnage
nous sommes d'accord pour qui un
étiquetage mais un étiquetage pour tours
si c'est pour le allèles il faut que ce
soit fait fait pour pour leur cacher et
pour le traditionnel comme ça chacun va
se trouver et il a rejoint c'est vivre
ensemble se redressent se respecter ne
pas s'imposer ne pas imposer les uns aux
autres
sa manière de consommer mais tant que
musulman je n'impose pas aux musulmans
de ne pas aller acheter l'avion
traditionnels
j'ai en tant que musulman je n'impose
pas aux musulmans de ne pas aller
consommer de la viande casher de la peau
soit capable et je ne voudrais pas qu'on
impose à la liberté parce qu'on a envie
de conscience de choix de consommer le a
l'air content content x6
si le non musulman veut le veau le
consommer c'est ce qu'on appelle la
liberté de la liberté de conscience et
la liberté de choisir
mettez je pensais sur la question est ce
qu'il ya des jeux j'ai entendu des
choses que sur lequel il ya comme des
précisions apportées le fait que les
musulmans vont consommer tant de tonnage
est pas plus moi institutions
institution représentative du culte
musulman je suis dans la capacité de
vous dire combien les misions d'en
consommer oui mais je pense que la seule
solution était trouvée ya quand même un
décret et un arrêté tout a été réglé
reconnaître tout arriver à cette
question a été réglée le travail en
arrêter elle décrit quatre sur la
question de l'étiquetage jojojura dit
encore ce que nous avons dit nous ne
sont pas pour que contre que le fait que
le consommateur soit informée sur les
produits qu'ils consomment
par contre ne souhaitant savoir dans
quel dans quel niveau cette information
émise par ce qu'est ce que c'est la
seule information de mon départ
doyen et puis lorsque c'est un forcément
doit doit être portée à au citoyen est
de 4 portée de façon équitable qu'il
perd kiné qui n'aucune qui n'aboutit pas
à la stigmatisation des musulmans
autre ça s'ajuste justien de préciser
cela parce que c'est important
c'est important que la formation soit
pas une information biaisée dans
laquelle au moment où trois d'un côté
les méchants et de l'autre côté les
gentils c'est parce que je pensais pas
l'objectif mais je pense vous avez bien
compris que c'est pas notre but ici
personne ici ne souhaite ça on veut tous
que tout le monde puisse travailler
vivre je vous dis ça parce que parce que
le score lorsque j'ai vu des compagnes
des compagnies d'affichage concernant
l'étourdissement nous l'étourdissement
sans étourdissement décoder que vous
allez mettre un étiquetage il faut il
faut aussi prévoir tu aurais des add des
compagnes de d'affichage montrons de
l'abattage classique et l'abattage et je
pense qu'il y est il faut il faut il
faut il faut il faut regarder ça
également il faible équité il faut de
l'équité mais on dit qu'il faut de la
transparence
il est tout à fait les gens sont
intelligents ils sont capables de
comprendre et plus on est transparent
plus on évite justement les
stigmatisations voilà pour les travaux
de la mission d'information du sénat sur
la filière viande si vous souhaitez en
savoir plus ou revoir cette table ronde
elle est disponible en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr bonne fin
de journée à tous